جدل يتعلق بهوس الجمال بين سيدات العالم
نساء يفضلن التسمير واخريات التبييض وبين
هذا وذاك اختلافات جماليه ومخاطر صحيه وفي
السودان الظاهره محل جدل دائم بين الفتيات
فاستخدام السودانيات لمنتجات التبييض
ورغبتهن الدائمه في تفتيح الوانهن باعتبار
البياض رمزا للجمال يثير الجدل في المجتمع
السوداني البعض يعتبر انها تتضمن تغييرا
للهويه في حين يوضح الاطباء ان مضاعفاتها
الصحيه خطيره الهوس بالبياض لم يقتصر على
النساء فقط بل دخل الرجل السوداني هو
الاخر في مضمار البحث عن كريمات التفتيح
تمثل صناعه منتجات تفتيح البشره 50% من
سوق منتجات العنايه بالبشره وبلغت قيمتها
السوقيه اكثر من سبعه مليار دولار في عام
2021 مع توقعات بان تصل الى حوالي 14.6
مليار دولار بحلول الفين
بمعدل ثانوي مركب يبلغ 7.7% من عام 2022
الى 2021
ونسبه المبيعات الاجماليه من المتوقع ان
تصل في عام 2004 الى 31.2 مليار دولار
واظهرت دراسه اجرتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
ان 40% من النساء في الصين يستخدمن كريمات
تفتيح البشره بانتظام وتصل هذه النسبه الى
61% بالهند و77 في نيجيريا كما اثرت دراسه
اخرى لمنظمه الصحه العالميه في عام 2017
ان اكثر من 70% من النساء في مصر يستخدمن
مستحضرات التبييض بافراط كما كشفت هذه
الدراسه ان هناك فتيات في عمر 10 اعوام
استخدمنا المستحضرات بغرض تبييض بشرتهم
على كل حال سال الناس في السودان ما رايك
في هواس النساء بمنتجات التبييض نتابع
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
انا شايفه انه يعني ما في داعي انه نحن
نغير لوننا فالطبيعه دي قبل حرفيا ما في
سبب مقنع بيخلي الواحد انه يغير لونه او
طبيعته العلو فهو ربنا اصلا لو كان عايزك
بشكل ثاني ما جابك بالشكل اللي انت فيه
فنحن نرضى به لو انه وبيشكلنا مهما كان
وبالحاجه اللي احنا فيها ونتقبلها يعني
انا مع الكريمات لانه هي لكل البنات يحب
الجمال احنا زمانك على الطبيعه زي ما قلت
الاخضر اخضر والاحمر احمر انا اسمراني
والاخضراني
كريمات دي ما عندنا على الطبيعي والله
يعني هي حاجه بين كويسه وبين كعبه هي ممكن
تستخدم المعقول ما لدرجه الامراض وكده
يعني ممكن تستخدم المعقول وتستخدم معه
مرطبات وكده انا ضد الكريمات لانه اول
حاجه بتغير
[موسيقى]
شكل الزول وانا شايفه انه الطبيعه احلى
واجمل السودان شمسنا حاره وبتعمل على
اسمرار البشره فانا معها ما يوصل لمرحله
الهوس انا اعتقد انه لو اهتمت الانثى او
اي من يبحث عن الطبيب لو اهتم بكماليات
الروح وبالوعي وبالثقافه يمكن انه يتقبل
المجتمع زي ما تقبل المجتمع كثير جدا من
السمر
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من الخرطوم الدكتوره نهله عمر
مؤسسه سكر كوزمتك دكتورة نهله يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معنا في صباح العربيه وعبر الهاتف
تنظمي لنا التغريد الخوابه عالميه ومقدمه
برامج اهلا بكم دكتوره نهله واهلا بك كذلك
تغريد طيب دكتوره ابدا معك بالفعل هناك
هوس في السودان لجهه تبييض النساء لبشرتهم
وما هو السبب هل هو ضغط المجتمع ام ماذا
صباح الخير صباح الخير على الجميع ايوه
نعم في هوس وفي هوس كبير جدا باستخدام
كريمات التبييض والهوس ممتد لفترات كبيره
حاليا في زياده في الوعي لكن لسه موجود
الهوس مشكلته الضغط جاي من الثقافه للجمال
في السودان احنا يعني دوله كبيره جدا
ممتده الاميال وشمال وشرق وغرب وجنوب
وكميه من القبائل وكميه من
التنوع الثقافي والتنوع الاثني فاحنا ما
ممكن نختزل كل الجمال ده في انه جمال
الفتاه السودانيين انها تكون صاحبه بشره
بيضاء مع انه على كل حال يا دكتوره اخذ
على كل حال يعني الشعراء والفنانين تغنوا
بالبشره السمراء وكثير من البيضات يرغبنا
في الحصول على بشره سمراء سمراء بامتياز
على كل حال خلينا نسمع وجهه نظر تغريد في
هذا الخصوص تغريد يسعد صباحك واهلا وسهلا
فيك معنا الا تعتقدين اليوم حسب ما يقول
البعض بان هناك بعض النساء اللواتي قمنا
بتبييض بشرتهن لديهن فقدان الثقه بالنفس
رغبه بالشعور بالامان العاطفي ولجانب رغبه
بالحصول على فرص عمل كيف تردين
فكلهن جميلات المراه السودانيه جميله لكل
اشكالها لكن بطبيعه المراه وبحاله المراه
هي دائما تبحث عن الجمال وتبحث عن مقومات
الجماعي
وهوس عمليات التجميل في العالم جميعا ليس
خسرا على السودان وانما السيد السودانيه
في بدايه خطواتها ويمكن تفتيح البشر
لسه في بداياته بطرق التقليديه
البحث يعني ما وصلنا
مرحله اخذ الحضن واخذ
كريمات دخيله تدخل الى السودان وتستخدمها
الفتاه من اجل التجميل لفتره
[موسيقى]
هي اللي تكتب البشره اكثر شمارين فمن هي
تتح
سن اشرار ترضيحه
طموح على الجمال تحديدا وترديها وسط
المجتمع بما
ان المستقدر بشره بي
ضاء من زمان جدا يعني
كان استخدام
مثلا
طويله جدا بعيد عن اشعه الشمس وادراكم في
جسمها كثير من طبقات الدخان الى ان يتم
حمايه البشره تماما من اشعه الشمس ومن اي
يعني
فلما تزال الصبغه دي بتقبل البشره بيضاء
[موسيقى]
من السودانيات انما هو في جميع
انحاء اهميه كبيره جدا
رغم وجود اليوم توعيه كبيره مقارنه
بالسابق لماذا لا يزال اقبال نساء
سودانيات على التبييض رغم مضاعفاته خطيره
والتحذيرات الصحيه
اوكي الصوت بيفصل لكن انا هجاوب على
السؤال اول حاجه هرد على استاذه تغريد انه
في فرق بين العنايه والاهتمام بالبشره
وفريق بين التبييض الطبيب انت بتغيري
الدرجات من درجات البشره من بشره سمراء
لبيضاء اذا ما في ثقافتنا سودانيه وثقافه
سره بالمنتجات العنايه بالبشره كانت
الثقافه ديه انه الدخان والدلكه وكل
منتجات السودانيه الغنيه دي كانت بتحتني
بالبشره انها تكون ناظره انها تكون ناعمه
انها تكون جميله ما كانت
بتتحدثها انها هي تبيض البشره حتى ولاحظنا
يعني في التاريخ السودان وسوريا سودانيه
زمان كان في تنوع واضح جدا في في جمال
السيدات والسودانيه من البشره السمراء
للبشره البيضاء
طيب تغريد انطلاقا من مقالته دكتوره نهله
تغريد اليوم يعني ما بتعتبري انه يعني انا
من خلال الحديث اللي انت بلشتي تحكي فيه
شعرت انك رابطه الجمال بالبياض يعني لماذا
لماذا تربطين جمال المراه بلون بشرتها يا
تغريد وبالبياض الا تعتقدين بانه فيه
تغيير للهويه وفيه العوده الى فكره سيطره
الابيض على الاسمر التي كانت وتلاشت منذ
سنين
نعم هي بصمه وضعها المجتمع هي بصمه يشترك
فيها ادم
لمطلبات لزوجته وانها هي تكون بيضاء اللون
وتكون صاحبه شعر طويل وكون صاحب وزن معين
هي وصمه مجتمعيه يطلبها المجتمع من كل
سيده انها يعني في ليله زفافها او حتى ما
بعد الزواج انها صاحبه بشره بيضاء ناصعه
وارتباط
طيب ما هو نفس الذي يطلب صاحب بشره سمراء
ما هو سوداني مثله مثلها
ولكن الاغلبيه والاكثر البشره البيضاء
وارتباطا الجمال
انما الان العالم والاجمال يعني تربانا في
عشر نجوميه يطلبن كثير من الغيار
[موسيقى]
وهكذا متطلباتها
نعم طيب يبدو ان دكتوره نهله عادت معنا
دكتوره نهله اليوم انطلاقا من حجه الذين
يدعمون انت تسمعيني جيدا
معنا نعم اسمعك اوكي دكتوره نهله اليوم
انطلاقا من حجه الذين يدعمون التفتيح
وتبييض بشرتهن الا تعتقدين بان الفتيات
اليوم هم ضحايا العنصريه المتجذره في
العالم منذ سيطره الابيض واستعباد ذوي
البشره السمراء وحتى المعايير المجتمعيه
التي تؤطر الصوره النمطيه للسمراء وتظهر
البيضه بانها متفوقه كل المجالات
نعم انا هرد عليك من من النطاق السوداني
للنطاق العالمي بالنسبه لينا في السودان
زمان السودان كان في تنوع واضح في حتى في
الصور القديمه في عنوان البشره السيده
السودانيه لانه كان الاهتمام وتراثنا اصلا
بتاعت جمال السوداني تراث كان فقط بيهتم
بنظاره البشره باستخدام مواد طبيعيه ما
كان بهدف لتغيير اللون لانه كان اللون
الاسمر ما كان يقل جمالا من اللون الابيض
لكن بسبب العولمه والاتجاه العالمي والضغط
العالم والعنصريه تجاه اللون الاسمر طبعا
بيحصل لها توسع في كل العالم ومنها وصلتنا
احنا في السودان الحاجه الثانيه مشاكل
الهويه برضو في السودان بين الهويه
الافريقيه والهويه العربيه الصراع ده
بيظهر في السطح في عنصريه تجاهل اللون
الاسمر فبالتالي حتى في ثقافتنا السودانيه
بتوجدت وظهرت عليه المصطلحات دخيله هي بقت
تستخدم في الصياغه اليومي العادي لكن هي
كلمات سلبيه وتخلط بيئه سلبيه للون الاسمر
مثلا هتقول كلمه من الكلمات يقول لك
الواحد انها تنظف لونها سواء كيف انت
تقولي لسيده نظفي لونك انك انت سيده سمراء
الاسمر ده يعني اوسخ او حاجه غير مرغوب
فيها فده بوريك عمق وتجذر المبدا تجاه
العنصريه تجاه اللون فبالتالي التغيير من
الناحيه دي محتاج تغيير على مستويات
مختلفه تغيير اجتماعي وتغيير بالنسبه
للدوله التغيير بالنسبه للدوله زي ما عملت
افريكا من 1970 بدات تعمل اجراءات ضد
الكريمات التبييض لحد ما وصلت حاليا
الدوله نمره واحد افريقيه عندها اقل نسبه
بتاعه استخدام كريمات تبييض لان هي حطيتها
في الاستراتيجي بتاعتها لانه نحن محتاجين
تغيير في الثقافه ومحتاجين تغيير في
القوانين بتسمح بوجود المنتجات دي تغيير
الثقافه بيجي من انه احنا يكون او في
ممثلين للبشره السمراء في كل نواحي
المجتمع زي الاعلام احنا اغلب الاعلام
المذيعات بكونوا دائما صاحبه بشره فاتحه
فدي حاجه برضه
للبنات انه دائما الشخص اللي انت بتنظريه
له دائما صاحب بشره بيضاء فبالتالي
التمييز الحاسه تجاهها البشره السمراء
محتاجين قصاد وتمييز ايجابي للبشره
السمراء ويكون فيه اكثر في الاعلان اكثر
في كل في المنصات وتمثيل اكثر ايوه تمثيل
اكثر في كل منصات عشان الفتاه السودانيه
الفدعه او في الثانوي لما تكون بتنزل سيده
اتنه هي نفسها تكون في نفس المكانه تشوف
سيده بتشبهها وجود التمثيل يعزز من الثقه
فقط يعني
اخيرا قبل ان نختم تغريد كلمه اخيره لك
دكتور
او بياضره بلدي الجمال
عنصريه او عندما تطلع
لشيء يعني اكثر من انه السيده هي تكون
واضحه من نفسها اكثر وتعمل الحاجه
اللي فيها
سمراء ولكنها تستمر اكيد في الوضع ده
تكون زاد بشره بيضاء فهي تبحث عن الجمال
وتبحث عن الثلث في نفسها
يكون في اتجاه
[موسيقى]
الازرق جدا لكم وشكرا لكل من تابعني وتحيه
لكل السيد السودانيه بكل
الوانها شكرا جزيلا لكما